obviously a very hot issue no pun
intended here let me ask first and
foremost what what about the claims that
a lot of these profiles on your site are
fake I mean I am not unfamiliar with
these kinds of adult sites and a lot of
times you'll see entries that seem
almost too good to be true yeah no I
appreciate the opportunity kind of you
know clarify things this is nothing more
than sour grapes right a former employee
who worked for three months plus a day
and one data probation you know wanted
to get a fast payday and so we are a
hundred percent committed to an organic
community there is no communication zero
that you'll ever have an awesome ass
with another member it isn't anything
other than organic and buy organic
meaning true and real one hundred
percent legitimate meaning every person
who signs up say I signed up to Ashley
Madison I found a girl with whom I
wanted to communicate and I start
talking to her there's no way that she
works for or is in any way affiliated
with your company or a company that
you're related to exactly that would
never ever happen zero chance that
happening is not a business process we
engage in now what can happen is a user
comes on with malicious and pretty
intense you know wants to take you to
their campsite we're pretty great at
detecting those fraudsters but if it
does happen if I ask you that person
gets through and you expend your five
credits now that communication will
refund it in two seconds we
automatically do so in fact once that
person is suspended we roll it all the
way back and so that happens very
infrequently it does happen from time to
time but make them to think about it
what you hear you know on the internet
is some sour grapes about any dating
service all I couldn't find the person I
was looking for well you know in our
site it's not an online brothel it's a
real service with real people and it
takes time to communication it doesn't
work for everybody we think we have a
great and high success rate and so
sometimes people want to blame the
service rather their communication
strategy bullet doesn't happen is that
you're having communications with some
sort of pseudo employee or some sake
that it's not what takes place on a map
talk to me quickly about the business
model how does this work just someone
sign up and browse the site for free and
then pay a certain amount per
or contact or per conversation how does
that work yeah exactly you know we're a
little different than other dating
services and that each communication to
initiate it costs credits there's no
there's no cost thereafter because we
don't want you to kind of create that
digital lipstick by moving it over to a
personal email account or leaving behind
a voice message so we try to encourage
you to keep on the Ashley Madison
platform but there is password protected
but there's no ongoing cost oh but yes
every initial communication has a cost
but all of those are the genuine people
but and you do have some sort of
security operation there to make sure
all of these people are real to make
sure it's not some sort of phishing
scheme to make sure i would say the
probably most common problem is that
prostitutes are operating through this
site yeah and think about it there is a
really natural way for a woman who
joined Ashley Madison to behave she
tends to sit back build a profile may be
shutting upload a photo so she's little
more comfortable she reads the
communication she received venture my
response will give them it's pretty rare
for a woman to sign up upload a public
photo and send out 25 communications out
of the gate if that happens we have a
high high probabilities we have a frost
or on our hand so we put them into a
queue we never deliver those
communications we watch we read the
communications if they're fake are
suspended and so that does happen from
time to time you're right people trying
to solicit people trying to move it over
a campsite we suspend all of those
profiles if you did get caught in that
we'd return your credits to you so you
can go and use them on the organic
search but ultimately actually not some
success in 36 different countries right
now I'm in South Korea for our lodges
because it is a genuine place where men
and women looking to have extramarital
encounters can do so and do so
successfully well in violent this just
dawned on me so slightly off topic but
have you ever had any interactions with
the NSA ever any concerns that Edward
Snowden's going to say at some point
that the US government is looking into
Ashley Madison's database no it's a you
know maybe you were saying that with
some sarcasm but maybe there's some
validity to those concerns for people
you know I think people having affairs
have often felt like oh my god I'm
exposed right it's why some jewelry
angry with General Petraeus when you had
as a pharaoh he could be compromised
well so much of what we've done here is
help create the perfect repair and so
the
non this way you use our service and the
protection we've created and where we
put our servers outside of America I
think gives a lot of credence that we've
never had an issue like that and I think
we're probably unsafe for terrain and
most ok 0 sarcasm by the way coming with
that question listen you are counters
your counter Susan suing Dory honest ill
Silva she's the employee that claims she
was hired to write fake fake profiles
how do you see this ending well think
about it you actually take a look at the
court document she submitted what she
submitted was QA testing right in the
technology firm you give quality
assurance you made sure that the site
works when you launch into a new country
like we just did and so she was also
instructed to build male profile she was
entrusted to do payment so would she be
saying / fraudsters so we're putting
through fake payments know where we're
running testing are and so yeah you have
to look at the person you have to look
at someone who has really been a
malicious inaccurate person right